the Joe Rogan experience so in even his
defense of that it's like I think
there's something wrong there yeah I
don't know what that something is well
there's a there's a sparkplug that's not
screwed in all the way there's something
wrong well speaking of fake personas I
feel like that's the worst when it comes
to politics yes and I do feel like one
there's very very very very very few
upsides of Trump in my opinion but one
of the upsides of Trump is that he did
kind of break the mold in terms of what
was viewed as the right way to
communicate as a politician because
before him you had all these very
measured people who had the proper
posture and they spoke with their thumb
pointed down because they don't want to
be strong with their their finger
pointing at you like that right so her
fist and then he comes along and he's
obviously shooting from the hip and he
clearly has no filter and he's tripping
over his words tremendous believe me
he's unnecessarily punchy and short with
his sentences and I remember there was a
report that came out that said he
communicates I think was like a sixth or
seventh grade level or something like
that and everybody in the media was
mocking it and I did a segment where I
said you guys are mocking and that's a
terrible idea because guess what though
the way he's speaking even though it
sounds stupid it's gonna pierce through
like you know how when some people talk
it's hard you have to focus to pay
attention to listen to where they're
going with it and he's barred and then
there's other people who talk and it's
like you just get it it's immediately
right in your brain and it doesn't
matter agree or disagree with the
substance of what that person is saying
you know when somebody's an effective
communicator and when he was out there
on the campaign trail and he was for
example campaigning in the Rust Belt
where Hillary Clinton did not go right
and he was like ah NAFTA NAFTA terrible
they shipped out all your jobs it was
unbelievably terrible and believe me let
me just tell you what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna keep your jobs here it's gonna be
unbelievable believe me that's pretty
good pretty good
people tell me twice a little off but
the matter is here excellent so I what
the [ __ ] thing he did recently where
he said that he would gone into the
school when the school shooting was
going on he'll run in there even if he
didn't have a gun yeah it's like imagine
saying that yeah you can't I was with
him when he was like listen the cops
should have gone in everybody's like
yeah of course the cops are gone in yeah
but then he has to gratuitously take it
so much further then he goes
I would have gone in and then he adds
without a weapon like now everybody
knows you're just full of [ __ ] Matt if
he was there as if he was there like if
Trump just happened to be there giving a
speech at the school and a school
shooting started and and he didn't do
anything he just stood on the outside we
know he would have it's a guarantee I
mean he's the guy who said I owe my
personal Vietnam was avoiding STDs at
the orgies I went to yeah that was isn't
it was not a scene in the dead zone yeah
didn't see the dead zone well in the
book in fact the guy uses someone to
shield him from a shooter and that's
what keeps that guy from ever becoming
president so it keeps him from pressing
the button because the guy was going to
become president and he was going to
launch a nuclear salt and nuclear war
and this guy that was Christopher Walken
skate was Christopher Walken was right
think so
he realized by touching this guy's hand
this guy was gonna do this and so there
was like some scenario that took place
where someone was trying to shoot him
and he used someone else to shield him
from the bullet and that's what
prevented him from ever becoming
president what's it's a movie the deads
owners it's a movie and it's also a it
was also a book by Stephen King okay
I've read the book and I saw the movie
I'm trying to remember who's it walking
yeah [ __ ] that's right that's right
young walking look at that handsome face
bastard it was a good weird-looking dude
ah where does where does it gets but
that's what's cool about him it's a
great movie though fun may might not be
great anymore this might be one of those
movies like I always told people we
should watch altered states it's amazing
and then I watch there's certain things
aged so bad we were talking about it I
don't know but especially with comedy
and you've pointed this out if you go
back and look at old comedy it's just a
different world they were letting stand
up and exactly you if you take the
conversation we're having and you like
somehow get it back to 1950 people look
at us like just the fact that we
casually curse and you know the concepts
we're talking about they be like this is
unbelievably impolite yeah you know what
I mean well one of the best examples I
think it's
even Colbert saying that President Trump
uses his mouth as Putin's [ __ ] holster I
just said it on you know whatever
network TV or Johnny Carson doing that I
mean no way go back to the old Ed
Sullivan Show you know where Jackie
Mason got banned for life because it
looked like he gave the finger he did
this thing right like you know this is
what I do I'm Jackie Mason he says he
never even gave him the finger but he
was accused of giving someone the finger
and that was it he was banned didn't
they do that with Elvis when he
performed he like moved his hips in a
way that they thought was too sexual
like we can't show this because there
are kids that exist in the world well
they would only frame him from the waist
up they wouldn't show all that [ __ ]
motion it was too much [ __ ] why Elvis
come on man that's so goofy like I don't
get what it is about different times I
mean there were just a few generations
away from the powdered wigs
[Applause]